[Music]
how's it going
bro ah what's up man i'm ready to
not lie that's alright we're lying dude
gotcha dave's my alibi we're good
i'm going with dave wherever dave goes i
go
i think dave is a little suspicious
actually i think
i'm stick with stinky as my alibi look
how scared he is
can we go here stinky god he's such a
non-team player this [ __ ] guy
it was stinky you followed me
i saw me do nothing
i thought he called the body i'm a
little obsessive dave to be honest you
made some weird movements but that's all
i got at the base
i was just checking to see what you guys
were doing and that sounds like
little liar boys anyway i found the body
in admin
all right dave definitely says all right
who's your teammate dave who do you work
with corpse
i forgot what it's like to play with
felix
you mean annoying was it was there
anyone else an admin
um no one else was in admin that i could
see charlie went down
to the left i think i'm over by the
navigation i was following to the right
yeah his movement was suspicious
wait dave did you kill julian um no
julia julian did david that was close
kind of
[Laughter]
me and felix were clear we found each
other i don't think it's feelings
or yeah because it is thank you dave
thank you so much i saw the market
together i was near grease ball for a
little bit jack and felix were in
electrical area right yeah
yeah we're electrical engines and then
cafeteria are you cooking moist man is
very
quiet i want to hear his liar voice
moist i was in a
navigation i had passed chris after
analyzing his movement pattern that
means nothing
all right i'm gonna skip for now but i'm
on to you
nice to meet you
this is his chance to prove himself he
should be thankful
yo don't leave don't leave don't lean oh
he left us huh interesting
if stinky is the other killer that would
be really cool actually
all right was anyone with dave oh they
said
there were two seconds left on the
reactor holy [ __ ]
it's ethan or chris yeah that's what i'd
eat
wait why the hell is that all right why
not felix can see through walls again
hold on felix why me because i don't
want you here
i hate it that he does wait his name is
corpse and he keeps finding the corpses
yeah we made that joke already yeah
that's all right i'm sorry has anybody
else
been with uh with sean or felix because
i
haven't i haven't even i haven't seen
ethan um
liar voice i can hear it
i can't believe we let felix get away
with this every single time if it's him
he just like
doesn't have an excuse yeah we should
know better by now
yeah oh wow there we go
wow wow you're done all right what's
next
yeah so we're killing chris next so
we all agree that it's chris yeah chris
why why
okay okay okay give him a chance all
right chris why i was i was
walking towards the oxygen which one no
i cleared that oxygen you were way too
slow
i was walking towards it thanks a lot
that does not help
me and corpse were at the top one and he
could have killed me so easily and then
felix did the other one
uh true i actually think it's correct i
could have killed you guys so many times
too but i didn't because i'm not the
killer
walking around no one died i'm confused
what the hell oh god i might have made a
mistake
i had to vote for you right or else
it would have tied oh i was actually
wrong for that i'm sorry
oh no are we wrong no you're right
oh i would have felt bad but i also
wouldn't chris you didn't you didn't
waste much time there didn't you
oh nice all right good luck i would love
to be imposter but i'll never get it
maybe next time who knows uh yeah it
works to see
who's greed's balls that's critical yeah
you gotta pick an alibi
i i'm 100 sure this is felix is the
imposter here
i'm staying glued to shawn's ass i'm
giving him no
breathing room all right
who did it who's dead oh two oh
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i mean sometime has passed
although me and moise and jack were all
together
for most of that and there was no dead
bodies on the right side yeah
i saw the left of cafeteria where i
found i believe it was dave blue yeah
i was kind of source of ethan until i
just saw him dead so i don't know what's
going on though
he really thought it was felix he was
doing some very suspicious movements
and uh that's why i was following him
around but tell me more
i followed you around [ __ ]
i literally said hey voice will vouch
for me because i was literally within
the whole game
right there was nobody in corpse and
electrical at one point like down below
i saw
both of them walking around doing stuff
wait felix what tasks did you do
oh no he didn't remember why come on
shut the [ __ ] up i was with you there
was no dead bodies
and just because i don't know which task
i did you're gonna vote me out i just
like voting you
that's a little weird everyone you know
you know i'm gonna vote you every round
anyway so
chad which class
yeah i kind of retract my vote
i think it's corpse and julian but
that's his
way okay fine i'll vote for you then uh
oh
that's a bit sucks that's a bit
oh it's definitely felix get me out of
here 100
good there's no doubt in my mind what do
i do
i got to do electrical if chris had
followed me there i feel like uh
that would be an indicator right
we'll see now yeah all right it was
chris
now we know it is chris i just found a
body
i was gonna say it's felix i was
connecting a lot of high-level dots in
my head
how's that working out i found a body at
the bottom below cafeteria
i was running from top left to bottom
running up every time no matter what
possibly him
he's so tough to read and try yeah i i
saw chris and julian julian went
into a room and went straight back out
of comms and i didn't see him do
anything in there
he did run by me and could have killed
me but three times sean
we passed each other in that bottom
hallway like three different times uh we
didn't high five
any of those times that's your fault i
have a handout i mean
i have zero lead other than possibly
chris so
i was in electrical doing uh some tasks
and then i went up back to med bay to
finish my feed
so who called the meeting again i did i
thought i was instinct was felix i had
it all planned out but it definitely it
is not now
i think it's fun because we have to vote
somebody
on the topic okay i came from the top
left and he would have i mean
i i feel like that's if you're that's
all you're you're only leading
down below you said you said you were
doing tasks what tasks were you doing
down below
me yeah i was doing the download
it's gonna touch oh [ __ ] it's gonna talk
oh oh we're dead we're so freaking dead
it's probably chris and julian unless
charlie's being a big brain
julian like um oh i could have done med
in front of everyone
wait you only need to kill one person
and we lose right yes yes i believe so
something like that so the reason i
think it's crazy is because i came from
the top left the body was in the
bottom middle and if i came from top
left he would have had to have come from
middle so he would have passed the
southern to go to the bottom left
but it's interesting that you're the one
who uh reported it
because i i didn't see it i'm voting
sean honestly oh
yeah it's chris and julian yeah i think
it's chris and julian
it's possible it's not chris like they
could have immediately killed the body
right before i walked in
but i highest probability i would say
chris what though and they both voted me
yeah i don't know about that
[Music]
get out of here chris tinker
we all stayed out of fear of dying but
julian was the only one who left
left i have tasked to do what do you
mean yeah we're nowhere near to getting
our tasks done man
yeah we're not do you guys not care
about tasks i don't
not at this point is it a jack or julian
i
[Laughter]
yes good luck have fun good luck
uh
should i report him can you hear me oh
no okay
so the first whole half of that round i
saw ethan and dave together pretty much
the whole time on cam so i was watching
security cam
yeah oh okay with dave and i did my
sample thing and then i left because
the time was going down to be fair ethan
and i did asteroids together and he
could have killed me
and it seems like he did it and the
battle went up after he did it well
let's just ask him ethan
deadass did you kill dave
[Music]
where did you find it i was literally
gonna say the last one i saw was you
but uh was me or was julian julian
electrical oh i did see an electrical
yeah
that's true i saw a storage going
towards electrical did anyone else see
corpse
i was i was around him a while he was
his movement was a little weird but he
was also definitely
so nervous what the [ __ ] was happening i
was just doing tasks yes i was doing the
wires
i'm in the most southern room next to
admin i believe at the moment
where's the box i don't know what to
believe it's an electrical
ethan ethan when did you part with dave
like when in that round
when i killed him pretty early on
like i went to i went and did medical
first
and that's when i was with dave and then
i went and did asteroids yeah what did
we do we got to make a choice
i think it's so obvious when it's me and
then i get nervous and then it goes to
my head
control your liar voice all right all
right it's cool
i'm going out too it was julian i saw
him take a freaking vent and he murdered
dude right in front of security where
you hang out all day
i was on security last round i was on
the asteroid machine that round so i
don't even know your heartbreak
dude i saw you killed i saw charlie
like right before you called the body
out no no no charlie was with me in
felix
[Laughter]
i'm so confused who else it is though
yeah i have no idea
okay what the f why did he lock me out
why am i locked in the thanks julian
julie's sabotaging me now
sorry julian i'm sorry
yo julian you gotta you gotta lock one
of them out
how many times do they have left how are
we doing on time
well that wasn't very well done i think
it's ethan you think it's who
he locked me in the cafeteria can you
hear me yeah who who did you say
he locked me and griezmann in the
cafeteria and then he stand uh greenspun
me i i'm i'm trying to think if it's you
as well it's either felix or ethan
sean you're walking around really weird
too to be honest this whole time
oh my god i was literally i was
literally clearing you to my channel
i don't think it's jack uh so it's felix
because i was in the [ __ ] cafeteria
yeah and he
killed greece right there dude sorry
okay you're trying to turn it back over
me i got it why didn't you why didn't
you say that immediately
because i was trying to figure out what
just can happen because it was me and
felix and chris
in the cafeteria and then i was like
wait who just got killed and it was good
and i was like wait was that who we were
wait wait chris
which camp are you smelling [ __ ]
from most because i know it's neither of
us
i think it's pewds why me because i'm
the one that reported it i literally saw
[ __ ] ethan do
it okay vote ethan out and then you can
do me
no no you out there
why would you skip if you saw me do it
oh that's crazy
damn it it had a header menu let's see
good luck guys julian i'm sorry i'm
sorry
oh ho ho quick all right so
right side of the map near the concrete
area
who's where right now currently
i'm an admin i was there with felix but
i didn't see if you actually remove the
oxygen thing or not
i did what was the code
[Music]
yeah there is a six in the numbers yeah
i can't even remember my birthday half
the time
corbin julian traded colors by the way
all right oh
that's pretty sus i wanted it back
charlie where were you at
oh you wanted it back huh yeah i killed
him charlie
with ethan i'm sorry sorry i couldn't
hear you i got big sus
energy on stinky what do you got to say
for yourself i came up to do oxygen
i swiped my card at the start and then i
went around you weren't at oxygen though
because that was going on no the
the the top one their top right one near
the weapons and navigation
i came in right behind ethan and i
pulled up the keypad and then a body was
discovered chris what's good with you
i'm going to follow jack and if he kills
me you know
all right where was the body sound logic
right part of the map
near like the cockpit area i don't know
the name of the o2
from one and i didn't see it with me
next round
uh what are we doing escape for what i'm
voting jack anyway
all right stop too late
wait jack and david suss i'm not gonna
go with them
what is that admin
uh is that moist yeah well god damn
why someone's pet just here man
imposters so [ __ ] easy
i thought he was gonna happen oh so he
called me
i saw [ __ ] and admin uh were you
struggling on that card
wait there's two people dead card is the
bane of my existence
you're there for a while crazy yeah wait
am i
crazy there's two people dead yeah even
died as well and feuds
i was just walking with um dave and
everyone
right we were all together yeah i saw
kristen i saw chris and felix at the
oxygen in
admin yeah grease ball i saw you go into
the admin so that checks out that you
just found the body rather than
self-report
unless it's a really quick killing who
were you with last round
in o2 charlie i forgot john ethan and i
at o2
i will say i thought it was ethan
because sean and i came in to o2
from the top and i didn't see ethan get
he said the body was on the right
but since he doesn't check out anymore i
think it might be sean because he's
he's really quiet he's never this quiet
no i'm quiet because every time i yell
everyone thinks that i'm [ __ ]
suspicious so i just
there's two killers so we're literally
yeah dave you could actually saw
charlie go into the i can like lightly
vouch for you and charlie on on this
round
i'm i'm feeling chris on jack on this
one i'd say let's vote chris hey then
it's not me chris i'm voting chris
it's not me what the heck well we need
to get rid of people
wrong i think it's jazz it's corpse it's
corpse heaven i think it's jack
they're all over the place but i think
we just lost if we got it wrong i think
charlie might have self-reported and it
was jack
with him damn it
dave whose team are you playing on what
the [ __ ]
well i was right behind you i was right
behind trying to see it and i just like
i thought
it can't be that quick he's so mad just
guys there's two people dead what the
hell
i usually know who it is at least i
don't vouch for the
killer like dave jesus christ think i'm
bad
no it can't be him he came from the
death room
oh no not again [ __ ]
oh he's gotta see that you almost got
away with it
you almost got away you always got away
with it
i just saw charlie kill someone in bent
someone
what's wait where you saw him vent
there's no possible way i went through
nav and then i went down to shields i
don't even know where the [ __ ] body
is
that's pretty good wait corpse where is
the body it's in the cockpit you took
the bend at the top i'm
pretty sure it was same it was in the
shadows but it was i it was blue for
sure
i i'm pretty sure so it's charlie or a
corpse
i think i might know the other killer as
well i'll put my light white
killer um i saw sean doing the
card task and he walked away before the
green bar went up at all
he did so david i'd say
david for like a bit and i was with
david i was scared to leave admin
because i thought sean was just camping
by the door to kill me and i just made
her
no i didn't leave because i wanted to
make sure ethan did it and it took him
all day and nothing happened until the
body was crazy
like i said no green bar can we go for
charlie corpse then sure
i'm gonna go with sean on this one i
haven't seen though i don't know what to
say about corpse but that with sean
seems a little fishy
hard to see be voting for sean to make
it ask
yeah well um also dave could have killed
me and he didn't just
i literally saw him jump in a vend why
are you guys hesitating
it doesn't tell us i say sean then
corpse
any last words shown you're that
determined that it's me
jesus christ yeah you really think it's
gonna be me and charlie again twice in a
row
[Applause]
let's go feel like you're not muted
killing time
[Laughter]
this is sub-optimal positioning for me
i are you [ __ ] serious this [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the 500th time
stop killing me i feel so bad doing that
to him every time
so do we do
no one was going for the oxygen i had to
get both of them
yeah i was at the button ready to spam
for the emergency meeting
oh no it really was killing time
i didn't go to do desk because i was
going to press the emergency button but
you can't press
on the oxygen times to die yeah i didn't
know that so you're looking pretty
suspicious
i was over by admin with somebody all
right i guess i do my little taskies huh
that's all right this is what i was
trying to do i need a new group of
friends for sure
all right how did you all just walk past
that body what body what buddy
uh there's a body i'm a hot target i get
it i just went from election
right where the fuel is no no no the one
next to storage it's by
you leaving oxygen right that was you uh
uh at
the top right i don't know the names of
things because you're going from top
right to bottom right right yes
yes okay i can't say that i can clear
dave because the bar went up and both of
us did the characters you guys think
it's julie
i didn't see it go up for ethan but we
were also together
pretty much the entire time charlotte
storage
charlie who did you see with us in in
the right way
from sports but i didn't see the color
it might have been ethan
or it could have been ethan down below
as well i i came from storage i was
heading to do the shields i saw
jack come from the left i saw it but you
said how did you not see that buddy
i literally did not see anything my room
didn't come up or anything yeah nobody
told me where you were you wouldn't be
able to see it i i can't i'm not even
i'm falling i'm following anywhere what
are they talking about
what oh you guys
[Applause]
at least i didn't say where he was or
something all right continue i'm dead
i don't know if ethan skipped because he
[ __ ] doesn't tell us
cool wow
let's go baby wow damn i just realized
that julian said [ __ ] all that round
yeah keeping quiet such a good tactic
all right corpse you're my alibi
see if this strike works
no don't kill me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you help me
ethan says he was chasing me i found him
i found the body what were you doing
there where was that
it was by reactor um corpse and i did
the reactor because like the
someone i guess made it uh and then i
found stinky's body in the hallway
we did react to it walked outside and
his body was in the hallway
with me no he wasn't felix ethan was
chasing you he was chasing me
into the thing where everyone was and
then he said
he was like oh everyone's here was
anyone with sean because so
he died on his way to reactor it seems i
saw
felix around electrical with me when i
was running up to reactor it's possible
it could have been him
ethan was behind me how would it have
been me he was chasing me
i saw you on electrical right so yeah
because if you were coming out of
electrical and i was running towards
reactor
and then the reactor was fine and so
then i turned around
to go back up towards cafeteria and
that's why i was following you through
there i feel like if anything we could
vouch for each other
because we were completely alone and now
there was killers there's there's two
killers
and there's okay you're cool ethan yeah
yeah i like that yeah julian's being
quiet again
where were you i was at the the bottom
where the oxygen on the right side
so when the oxygen got called i was
doing tasks so i ran over as soon as it
got it was it was it was reactor not
boxing that was called
i think it's corpse and ethan just
because they kind of vouch for each
other i didn't vouch for him
i didn't bad
yeah but there's a triangle of trust
here and i'm the
no i i didn't vouch for ethanol
why do you vote for me they you're the
only one
you're the only one that voted me what
the [ __ ] was that
explain yourself all right let's see if
it's ethan
do it ethan do the visual pass
i say that
no i can't click it oh he didn't kill me
visuals are off okay okay okay
why did we turn that off that's like for
fun
let's go dude eighth invited
jack that was an accident i did not mean
to jump into that vent in front of you
so i was like well i have to kill him
you saw me jump into a vent
oh i didn't see and i thought it was so
both of you went down to do the reactor
so i was like okay it's not crystal
corpse because they did it
and bang dang two steps away triangle
means nothing apparently too i didn't
know i never vouched for you than
ever wait is that what made us lose was
the oxygen yeah we died
dude wow wow we do want visual tasks
yeah oh yeah sure see i was looking at
you ethan i was like ethan just doing
he's not faking it but then i was like i
was so sure that you were gonna kill me
i totally thought that you were coming
in there to kill me i was like good
triangle of trust bro i never break it
all right then triangle of trust we
gotta find a third boy
no one's doing the oxygen
[Laughter]
we're going to lose because that was
okay that's funny
i always picked the wrong people
oh baby somebody left a body by admin
poor felix
and i stand right after him yeah you and
me are both good we both have our uh
okay so asteroids went down to do oxygen
and i thought triangle meant something
but i guess not kind of ran with me and
then ran away as soon as you saw ethan
chris chris knight scan top left okay so
it's
he probably just reported dave like
because he's imposter and wanted someone
up if it's not dave
it wasn't dave then or they only had a
wife that was watching the stream
and that gave me some water
oh my god did you hear me oh legend
thank you
but g fuel that's like that will keep me
up
best wife queen march gives water
thank you marge
the body's in electrical i will say
corpse i watch
do the leaf task where he blast that out
the the ship [ __ ] so he's safe
i don't think ethan could have gotten
there in time and i definitely think we
got it right with dave
i followed julian around i did see ethan
go
down from cafeteria when we were locked
in cafeteria julie and i went
julian and i went left ethan went south
which is
towards electric could have gotten there
and killed chris there
well i shouldn't really be alone here
let me do a little reconnaissance let's
see what i see
the tasks for now i'm gonna go check i i
think i think for sure it's sean
i'm i almost want to call on him what
what his his kill had to be on cool down
then i followed that man for like 30
minutes
it's orange
wait what do you mean i literally just
why didn't you report the body no no me
and corpse were over by comms you went
off with charlie and now charlie's dead
you jump out event on the security cams
bro
who just walked by our body
yeah no man you got it wrong
we got it right with dave but wrong with
ethan it's definitely julian he put it
for himself
there's no comeback from there's
[Music]
wait was it dave or ethan it was me and
julian
immediately after he was like trying to
trash
i kind of want to just immediately kill
chris because he's the only one that's
going right
i might do that
oh my god uh yo okay this is gonna be
super obsessed with me
but me and ethan were in uh jesus two
people are dead yeah me and ethan were
in
what the [ __ ] is it called like the
security thing security yeah
and we i saw uh grease ball walk over uh
uh chris's body on the camera i didn't
see any bodies yeah yeah cause you hear
the
kill where were you okay wait wait wait
you saw him walk over a body
yeah two people touch me i came from
communication into storage
okay but i was also looking at security
did you not see him
i didn't see that it's ethan and charlie
people that saw me come from
communications
might be crazy they've all cleared each
other right that's right it literally
was
yeah grace ball where were you so
graceful come in from the side so let's
vote
ethan first then felix then no no no no
no no [ __ ] first because he's the
one i saw on the camera
don't listen to dave all right yeah but
that's the that's the obvious one then
we have him then and we know it okay get
him out
first and it is telling us that he saw
[ __ ] walk on top of a body
yeah on the camera and for some reason
ethan didn't see it which is really
sucks was ethan on cams with you or yeah
he was i mean
i might have seen it you might have seen
it before me because i was
i didn't know how to get the security
you didn't look at the camera yeah i
believe
i believe that what if ethan was just
standing at cams and not actually so
waiting for the cooldown
it's possible okay i'm done with ethan
and then charlie no
charlie first please love god i wish the
two people why would we vote on the one
that i didn't say
walked over the body that makes me not
[ __ ] saying so shall we come into
storage oh you guys
all right i sus jack and david not
voting charlie because then it's obvious
that it's him
what does that mean felix you called
that out you didn't even vote
yeah because it's uh charlie that's a
good point
our game are you playing they make no
sense
i saw a guy walk over the body all right
let's vote for the other guy
all right what's the threat then explain
this okay so we got
we got someone else's if you're so sure
that it's charlie we
then initiate the charlie belt right or
i'm fine with that as long as you vote
out pewds on the next one
it's jack and charlie literally oh
[ __ ] it is ether or felix okay but have
i done something
that was suspicious no have charlie done
it
yeah all right wait felix felix
all right you should have you guys are
getting played and it's pretty cringe
bro come on
okay what kind of game are you playing
you're voting
why is no one turning it off god damn it
are you guys gonna listen to the top one
you're [ __ ] dumbass everything i said
checked out but
let's vote out everyone else i don't
know why what is that strategy explain
that david
he killed me in the reactor room but i
thought you guys explain yourself david
jack now
you're a [ __ ] idiot i want to know
certain kinds this stories you're still
going i say it i saw greece fall on cam
i was with ethan let's spot out everyone
else
what is this
if he had him dead to rights why did he
not get that vote done oh that feels
amazing
felix i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened they just didn't want to
believe you
wait barry is still level one
and you haven't fed bob god damn signals
19 year olds because their new trials
mode
is like use your full pixeling ruses to
defeat as many enemy waves as possible
download pixel links instantly for 20
muscle increase oh
[Music]